I would consider myself a
paleoanthropologist so I study humans
but in the past
we know that fire has been around for a
long time at least a million years then
the question is what's been the evolving
relationship that humans and human
ancestors have had with fire
I spent a lot of time surveying and
leading excavations in Malawi which in
sort of Southern central Africa
we thought it was going to tell us
something about this particular time
period where we start to see a really
pretty substantial increase in the
complexity with which humans early
humans are making stone tools and just
kind of making different kinds of
artifacts
foreign
based on the research that had been done
by our colleagues in sort of the
geosciences that there had been periods
of time in the past when that Lake was
rising and falling and in some points in
time it was basically just gone
[Music]
we were thinking how would that have
affected people on the kind of the broad
scale our colleagues they drilled this
massive core down into the sediments of
the lake they pulled up all of this mud
and in the mud is this record of past
vegetation and past fire history because
there's little bits of charcoal that end
up in the system when there's more
burning on the landscape they were still
busy working through the majority of
their results at the same time that we
started our archaeological project
we were working in parallel and sort of
overlapping a bit and it wasn't really
until we had this kind of one
conversation where we realized that we
were both kind of coming up against the
same problem we were finding that all of
the archaeological sites that we were
discovering dated to a very specific
time period and that was all within the
last 85 000 years they were discovering
that they were finding a lot of evidence
for major ecological turnover and
environmental change that they couldn't
readily explain using climate variables
alone and that was also within the last
85 000 years
and so it kind of wasn't until we had a
conversation with each other that we
knew that we had complementary data sets
that were really going to tell that
story together
[Music]
foreign
often is this destructive tool that
doesn't have to be the case because if
you have the right kind of ecological
knowledge and you know exactly where and
when to set the fires and how to control
them what you can actually do is you can
shape the landscape to do your bidding
in a sense can clear out undergrowth
strategically and then you can make new
grass come up and that draws in all of
the animals that like to hang out in
those kinds of habitats so you can sort
of engineer the world around you what we
came out with was I think a pretty
interesting result we were expecting the
environment and the climate to have
influenced the people but really what we
found is it was people who were
influencing their environments
[Music]